j'ai essayé de porter à la fois des
valeurs des principes les engagements de
François Hollande sur l'ensemble de ces
territoires je vois d'abord féliciter
mes amis
kerabouziane et Laurent grogguillaume de
leur victoire et ça me fait chaud au
cœur de les voir triompher ainsi et de
porter au sein du Parlement à la fois
leur voix et aussi leur talent féliciter
aussi monsieur Delatte pour sa victoire
avec le Front national parce que lorsque
l'on fait une simple addition on
s'aperçoit en fait que la somme des
voies de l'UMP et du Front national sur
cette circonscription on aboutit à ce
chiffre de 52 et donc je le félicite
d'avoir après cet appel sur Gazette info
indiqué clairement qu'il avait des
valeurs communes avec le Front national
ce qui n'est pas mon casque qui est loin
d'être mon cas et donc je regrette
l'absence de débat de démocratique
notamment puisque vous avez souhaité
lancer plusieurs débats une une fois je
suis seul mais ça fait quand même la
deuxième fois que je déborde nous savons
pas encore si il va venir ou pas
moi en tout cas je l'ai attendu très
très longtemps très longuement au-delà
de ces éléments c'est tout même
inquiétant
il s'est passé un phénomène politique
majeur la digue entre l'UMP et le Front
national a été rompu et donc maintenant
on a en fait une forme d'arrangement
entre les deux parties parce que
visiblement compte tenu de ceux qui
m'est revenu sur le terrain il y a eu en
effet mobilisation tant mieux il y a eu
aussi que addition des deux électorats
sur là aussi cette crainte ses peurs qui
ont été agitées mais c'est la vie
démocratique bon je respecte le choix
démocratique de la majorité je
remarque et observe que entre le premier
tour le second tour plus de 4500
lecteurs se sont rassemblés sur mon nom
je les en remercie et le combat continue
maintenant il faudra là aussi aller plus
loin et je suis heureux que le Parti
socialiste et la majorité présidentielle
soit confortée au sein du Parlement pour
mener à bien l'ensemble des engagements
du Président de la République